[Music]
along with the return of a popular
Marvel series we're bringing you another
film installment in a popular horror
franchise and another TV installment in
a popular horror franchise plus the
third outing for a certain French thief
and Master of Disguise and an erotic
Thriller with Alden Aron Reich it's all
coming up on this week's what to watch
we have a little bit of a situation we
wanted to run by you Mobius wow wait to
see you
again that that's what's been happening
wow finding its way into our timeline
once again is Loki season 2 look no
further than the Tomato Meter score for
a reason to check out season two given
that it's certified fresh at 84% with
the critics consensus saying Loki's
dizzying dazzling second season May rely
on slight of hand to distract from its
slightly less satisfying storyline but
the end result still contains enough of
that old Marvel magic to entertain the
second reason to give the second season
a chance is that thanks to the events at
the end of season 1 there's a whole new
set of C circumstances for Loki as he
tries to piece things together and also
remakes friends with Owen Wilson's
Mobius who no longer remembers what he
and Loki have already been through plus
Loki is struggling with the condition
known as time slipping sounds like
something my manager has asked me about
the third reason to try out season 2 is
that at some point this series should
play a major role in setting things up
for the future movies given the heavy
featuring of Jonathan Majors as well a
few different characters like he who
remains Victor timely and dare we say k
baby you've been gone 3
[Music]
days overtaking theaters this week is
the Exorcist believer the first reason
to believe this one is that it marks the
sixth installment in The Exorcist
franchise and even more importantly it's
a direct sequel to the original 1973
certified Fresh The Exorcist and with
that and this is reason number two the
film features Ellen Burston reprising
her role as Christmas mcneel from that
original her first time returning to the
franchise in 40 years she's joined by
stars like Leslie odm Jr andow and
Jennifer Nettles the third reason to get
possessed I mean obsessed with this
movie is that this is the first of three
new Exorcist films coming our way in the
next few years yes please the next one
called deceiver is coming in 2025 you
see the news is that Chucky in the white
house we're responsible for Chucky we're
going to DC he knows where my sister is
we're going to Chucky guys getting all
dolled up for its third season is the
horror series Chucky the first reason to
give this one a try is that it's of
course based on the child's play film
franchise serving as a sequel to number
seven Cult of Chucky and even better is
that the series also features Brad Duff
rep prising his role as the voice of
Chucky the next reason to tune in is
that the first two seasons were a hit
with an impressive audience score
average of 87% and both seasons fresh at
over 90% on the Tomato Meter the critics
have called it a bloody good time
naturally with both absurd humor and
creative horror sounds like Chucky
thirdly in this new season it looks like
our boy Chucky is now targeting the obal
office and a very clueless first family
that has no idea what they're dealing
with returning to Netflix for its third
season is the French mystery thriller
Lupin or lupon the first reason to try
this one out is that it brings a new
take on some classic material as it
follows a man who is inspired by the
stories of Master Thief aren lupon a
character created by Maurice Leblanc in
the early 1900s reason too is that it
features Omar Sai in the leading role an
actor whose impressive work you would no
doubt recognize from the takedown and a
couple of Jurassic World movies and the
critics love him in lupon speaking of
critics the third reason to tune into
lupon is that the first two seasons are
very certified fresh on the Tomato Meter
with a consensus that this is an
engrossing Espionage Thriller and if
early reviews are any indication season
3 is headed that way too getting married
we're getting
married wish we could tell the whole
world we're going to have to tell them
sooner than later morning morning and
finally keeping us honest is the erotic
Thriller fair play after debuting at
Sundance back in January this film is
already certified fresh at 85% on the
Tomato Meter with critics comparing it
to the best '90s nail-biting Thrillers
that's the first reason to check this
one out the second is that it features
Alden Aon Reich everyone's second
favorite Han Solo as he Stars alongside
Phoebe Denver as a couple whose
relationship is put to the test after an
unexpected big promotion at a cultural
hedge fund how that sets up an erotic
Thriller it's all part of the fun I
suppose another reason to give this one
a try is that it marks the big screen
directorial debut for Khloe damont who
also wrote it she previously worked as a
director and writer for the fresh HB
series Ballers love a good directorial
debut oky doie fresh fam five picks that
are almost as fun as playing with a
psychotic killer doll be sure to let us
and your fellow viewers know in the
comments what you did check out whether
it was on this list or not remember to
check out Ron tomatoes.com for the
latest updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay
freshh